en el vídeo anterior vimos la curva de
valoración para la titulación de una
base débil con un ácido fuerte y
encontramos el ph en dos puntos de la
curva el primero antes de agregar el
ácido que sería este punto y corresponde
al inciso a y en el inciso p encontramos
el ph después de agregar 20 mililitros
del ácido que corresponde a este punto
ahora en el inciso c
nuestro objetivo es encontrar el ph
después de agregar 40 mililitros de
nuestra solución 0.1 molar de hcl
entonces cuántos moles te has ido
agregamos bueno la concentración de hcl
es 0.1 molar y como la polaridad es
igual a moles / litros queremos conocer
los moles y agregamos 40 ml
que al mover el punto decimal uno dos
tres lugares es igual a 0.04 litros
agregamos 0.04 litros entonces
simplemente multiplicamos 0.1 por 0.04 y
eso es igual a 0.00 4 agregamos 0.004
moles de hcl que lo podemos ver como h
más y cl - así que tenemos 0.004 moles
de h más que al estar en solución
podemos decir que h más yo h - forman el
guión y tronío h 3 o más así que tenemos
0.004 moles de h 3 o más
con cuántos moles de amoniaco empezamos
bueno la concentración era 0.1 molar la
concentración de amoniaco al inicio era
0.1 molar que es igual a moles / litros
empezamos con 40 mililitros de amoniaco
es decir 0.04 litros así que para
calcular los moles simplemente
multiplicamos 0.04 por 0.1 y eso es
igual a 0.004 moles de amoniaco nh3
entonces el ácido que agregamos en la
titulación reaccionará con la base que
teníamos al inicio escribamos la
reacción de neutralización una forma
sería nh3 + h 3 o más el h 3 o más dona
un protón al amoniaco y se forma n
h 4 más y como el h 3 o más pierde un
protón nos queda h2o esta es una forma
de escribir la reacción otra forma
podría ser nh3 + hcl donde el hc l dona
un protón al nh 3 y se forma nh 4 más y
como el hc el dona su protón nos queda
cl - el a nyon cloruro muy bien ahora
agregamos 0.004 moles del ácido 0.004 y
también empezamos con 0.00 4 moles de la
base 0.004 observen que la relación
molar es 1
aun así que hemos agregado suficiente
ácido para que reaccione completamente
con la base entonces esto representa
el punto de equivalencia este es el
punto de equivalencia de la titulación
todo el ácido reaccionará y por lo tanto
neutraliza a toda la base perdemos todos
los 0.004 moles de nh 3 y como el
amoniaco se transforma en amonio nh4 más
si empezamos con cero moles de nh 4 más
lo que perdemos de amoniaco es lo que
ganamos de amonio así que ganamos 0.004
moles de nh 4 más y después de agregar
el ácido nos quedan
0.004 moles de nh 4 más así que tenemos
amonio presente en el punto de
equivalencia y cuál será su
concentración bueno la concentración de
amonio es
amo les sobre litros tenemos 0.004 moles
de nh cuatro más entre cuál es el
volumen total bueno
regresemos al problema empezamos con 40
mililitros y agregamos otros 40 40 más
40 es igual a 80 mililitros es decir 123
0.08 litros nuestro volumen total es
0.08 litros
entonces 0.004 entre 0.08 es igual a
0.05 tenemos una concentración 0.05
molar de nh 4 más ahora el amonio es un
ácido débil y puede reaccionar con el
agua entonces sí
h 4 más reacciones con el agua de la
solución el amonio funciona como un
ácido y dona un protón al agua con lo
que obtenemos h 3 o más y drone y como
le quitamos un protón al nh 4 más nos
queda
nh 3 amoníaco como el amonio reacciona
con el agua eso afecta el ph observen
que el nh 4 + reacciona con el agua pero
el año en cloruro casi no reacciona así
que no tenemos que preocuparnos por esto
solamente el nh 4 más afecta el ph y
nuestro objetivo es encontrar el ph
entonces la concentración inicial de nh
4 más es 0.05 al inicio es 0.05 y
nuevamente supongamos que no tenemos
ningún producto en el cambio verde
una cierta concentración de amonio que
reacciona con el agua perdemos equis y
eso que perdemos de amonio se transforma
en amoniaco entonces si perdemos una
concentración x de amonio la ganamos de
amoniaco y por lo tanto también ganamos
esa concentración de h 3 o más
finalmente al equilibrio tenemos una
concentración 0.05
x de nh cuatro más para el h 3 o más nos
queda x y para el nh 3 también nos queda
x ahora como el amonio funciona como un
ácido es decir dona un protón al agua la
expresión de equilibrio que vamos a
escribir es acá acá a es igual a la
concentración de los productos entre la
de los reactivos así que tenemos la
concentración de h3
más x por la concentración de nh 3 que
también es x entre la concentración de
nh 4 más que es 0.05 x ahora en el vídeo
anterior calculamos el valor de caja
para el amonio y encontramos que es
igual a 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 y esto
es igual a equis cuadrada entre 0.05
menos x pero supongamos que x es una
concentración muy pequeña y por lo tanto
0.05 menos x es aproximadamente igual a
0.05 usemos la calculadora tenemos 5.6
por 10 a la menos 10
0.05 y a esto le sacamos la raíz
cuadrada x es igual a 5.3 por 10 a la
menos 6 x es igual a 5.3 por 10 a la
menos 6
recordemos que x representa la
concentración de iones cidronio al
equilibrio x es la concentración de
iones sidronio finalmente calculemos el
ph el ph es igual a menos el logaritmo
de la concentración de iones hidronew es
decir menos logaritmo de 5.3 por 10 a la
menos 6 usemos la calculadora menos
logaritmo de 5.3 por 10 a la menos 6 es
igual a 5.28
h es igual a 5.28 observen que en el
punto de equivalencia nuestra solución
es ácida encontremos este punto en
nuestra curva de titulación también
llamada curva de valoración agregamos 40
mililitros de nuestro ácido y obtuvimos
un ph de 5.28 este punto corresponde al
inciso c y el ph es igual a 5.28 este es
nuestro punto de equivalencia
finalmente en el inciso d nuestro
objetivo es encontrar el ph después de
agregar 60 mililitros de nuestra
solución 0.1 molar de hcl entonces
cuántos moleste ha sido agregamos bueno
sabemos que la concentración de hcl es
0.1 molar y esto es igual a moles /
litros nosotros agregamos 60 mililitros
es decir 0.06 litros
entonces si multiplicamos 0.1 x 0.06 eso
es igual a 0.00 6 agregamos 0.006 moles
de hcl recuerden que hcl se compone de h
+ y cl - así que podemos decir que
tenemos 0.006 moles de h + cual
el protón al agua formamos h tres o más
así que tenemos 0.006 moles del ácido
ahora en el inciso c
vimos que necesitamos 0.004 moles para
que el amoniaco reaccione completamente
así que en este punto perdemos 0.004
moles del ácido que reaccionan con el
amoniaco y nos quedan 0.002 moles de
ácido en la solución entonces para
calcular el ph necesitamos conocer la
nueva concentración de iones hidronew
así que la concentración de iones
hidronew es igual a los moles que en
este caso nos quedaron 0.00 todos entre
el volumen total que es igual a 40
mililitros más 60 mililitros es decir
y litros así que nuestro volumen total
es igual a 0.1 litros 0.1 entonces 0.002
entre 0.1 la nueva concentración de
iones hidronew es 0.02 molar
finalmente calculemos el ph el ph es
igual a menos el logaritmo de la
concentración de iones hidronew es decir
menos el logaritmo de 0.02 usemos la
calculadora menos logaritmo de 0.02 es
igual a 1.699 nuestro ph es igual a
1.699 que lo podemos redondear a 1.70
para que sea más fácil entonces tenemos
un ph igual a 1.7 después de agregar 60
mililitros de nuestro
al agregar 60 mililitros de ácido el ph
es muy cercano a 1.7 así que hemos
pasado el punto de equivalencia en
nuestra curva de titulación